so i want to ask you
why won't you watch dune
because i'm so attached to the original
dune the david lynch one did you love
that one oh it's one of my favorite
movies of all time and you loved it the
reason being is because the way he
captured that world is if there's grit
and dirt you know like the harkonnen
planet like yeah sting was in it you
know what i mean
and it was just it was gritty and i i
just i love that movie but did you watch
the documentary the jodorowsky's dune
no
um
so you're saying this new one's like
star wars okay just stop for a second
okay
first of all there's a documentary
called jodorowsky's dune
that i highly recommend you watch
the og one no it's not about that it's
about a guy who had his own vision of
doing what did it what did jodorowsky do
oswell he did another movie that was
weird what
yeah magic mountain yeah so this weird
guy right back in the 70s wanted a dune
he almost got it made
and it it shows how it never happened
okay it was as if
um someone didn't believe in george
lucas and star wars yeah like if this is
if something so that's that's the
documentary it's and it's about the
movie dune about before david lynch did
his this dude try to he was too ahead of
his time he was too ahead of his time
people couldn't understand what he was
trying to make okay so the guy that
directed the new dune is the guy that
did arrival so good yes you know i kind
of like arrival and did you see so good
yeah the second blade runner yes the
same guy the new blade runner 20 yeah he
did that too so it's going to look clean
and it's going to be good and the
music's probably going to be able to
be good and i've heard read some [ __ ]
um reviews on it and they said that it's
a la it's an epic and that it might be
kind of like star wars wow well let me
play devil's advocate they're redoing
lost boys right yeah are you going to
watch the new lost boys if they do if if
the reviews are good because the
original is the best
it could be better than the original
yeah do you think things can be better
do you agree
it's hard to jeremiah
nostalgia
yeah i don't know yeah it's amazing
because it's like a slice of of time
like is it going to be set in the 80s
again or is it going to be an updated
lost boys
is is there going to be an epic sax guy
in it
yeah that was amazing you know listen
okay when you see the trailer of the new
ghostbusters
what they're redoing that how many times
are you going to remake that movie
there's a new one there's a new one oh
god all right
ask andrew santino you can't beat out
bill murray dude stop for a second all
right dan awkward's in this movie he is
well that's uh i think that's a good
yeah
is bill murray i don't know probably not
but then who cares
yeah okay but just let me finish
when you look at the trailer
you could you'll feel some of the magic
of the old movie
because when i saw the trail i didn't
know they had made a new one i was in
the movie theater i was watching james
bond right what'd you think loved it
didn't you yeah epic right and i was
sitting in the theater with my my little
chinese friend
yeah
and we saw the [ __ ] trailer for
ghostbusters him and i both looked at
each other
we had tears in our eyes
and we did we did this in the theater
we had
ch chills there's shivers the shivers
did wow
that's how good the [ __ ]
trailer was well
we shouldn't discount it then um yeah
i'll check it out one of my point is is
that they can still
depending on who it is they can still
take an old ip
is that what they call it intellectual
property intellectual property
thank you you're welcome and still make
something good
and creative
okay right but aren't there certain
movies they ca you cannot read like they
can never remake the exorcist
they have they have there's so many
different versions there's like
speaking of the exorcist we went to
visit
jenny
tell them the story our cousin jenny
oh yeah yeah yeah cousin you went to
thanksgiving i met your cousin i love
her yeah yeah we went there we went
there the best what happened i love it
i love that whole side of your face
there's something i forgot as a child go
ahead do the she said the king kong and
then
oh yeah
well so we were talking about how steve
is the sweeter libra